four uh z minus one on
z minus i uh to be real that's the first
one
that i'm doing so i'm gonna write to be
real
what we need to say is that the
imaginary part
of z minus 1 on z minus i that has to be
0. now i can see because i separated out
in the previous
part of the question this right here
this
is the imaginary part of z minus 1
z minus i so all i need to do is solve
for this thing
being equal to 0. now i hope you can
agree that it doesn't matter what the
denominator is equal to as long as the
numerator
is 0 then the whole thing will be 0. so
therefore i can say
i e x plus y minus 1
equals 0. and i can just tidy this up a
little bit make y
the subject i guess i would subtract x
add 1.
and amazingly i get this very very
simple shape it's just a straight line
with a gradient of
negative 1 and a y intercept of 1.
now this looks really good but there's a
bit of a problem
there's something which we kind of
ignored early on which we need to draw
our attention back
to if you have a look at this original
question right we want z minus one on z
minus i
to be real and it's a bit sneaky here
because we haven't really been thinking
these terms for a while but
this expression here it actually has a
discontinuity built into it there is a
value
that z is not allowed to take otherwise
the universe of mathematics explodes
what is that value maybe my uh my sort
of introduction to it might be able to
tell you right
this denominator here z minus i z minus
i
can never be zero because you can't
divide by zero we have learned in
complex numbers you can take square
roots of negative numbers
still not allowed to divide by zero so
that's a way of saying
z minus i cannot equal 0.
but we could equally write that as z
cannot equal i now the reason why this
is important to me
is because that number that complex
number i
is actually going to be on this line
here
because if you think about this let's
actually draw it now if you think about
what
y equals minus x plus 1 what it looks
like
as we mentioned before it's got a
y-intercept
of 1. that's on the imaginary axis here
in fact that makes its intercept i so
i guess we have to say that this point i
is
normally would be on you know considered
as part of a locus here
lucas i should say but we had to exclude
it due to this domain restriction that
was implied by the question itself
so therefore i've got a big hollow
circle there and now i can draw the rest
of my
uh locus so there goes the line with
gradient negative 1 off to the left and
to the right
you can see we should get that intercept
there at 1 and you can test this
this lucas out right if you put in a
spot like z equals 1
you get 1 take away 1 on
1 take away i well you get 0 on the
numerator so
therefore 0 is that a real number yes it
is
you can test some less trivial numbers
if you want for example
if we go over to say here so i'm going
to call that 2
and this down here means if you have a
look across
because we know the gradient is negative
1 that should be negative i
down there so therefore if we test i'll
just write over here
test z equals 2 minus i
i'm going to pop it into this z minus 1
z minus i over here let's try it out i'm
going to get
2 minus i minus 1 divided by
2 minus i minus i what do we get here
well 2 minus 1 gives you 1. there's no
other is on the numerator on the
denominator you get 2 minus 2i
and you can clearly factorize out this 1
minus i factor on
the denominator or you can factorize out
a 2 so that gives me 1 minus
i on 2 outside of 1 minus i so cancel
cancel we just get a half which is
indeed
a real number and you can check anywhere
else along
this line so long as you don't include i
because it leads to this discontinuity
you are fine okay so that was part a
for it to be real now i want to do part
b
which is for it to be imaginary now for
z minus 1 on z minus i to be imaginary
we can use the same kind of logic that
we employed before which is to say
i want the real component over here i
want that to be equal to 0. so i'm going
to write that down first
the real part z minus 1 on z
minus i that has to be definitely equal
to 0.
but i've already kind of flagged myself
that this is not the only thing you must
consider for instance
we're going to have this same domain
discontinuity that we had before that's
a bit of an issue
but in addition to that you can see if i
want
z minus 1 on z minus i to be imaginary
there is a single case in which
even though the real part is 0 you still
might not get an imaginary number
and that is if the real part is 0 and
also if the imaginary part is zero so
this is a bit sneaky right
when you have a look up here right if
the imaginary part is zero
what you get left with has to be a real
number okay but if the imaginary part
and the real part are both zero
then you're just looking at 0 that's not
an imaginary number that's a real number
so therefore i have to say there's
actually a problem not from the
denominator
well there is a problem with the
denominator but there's also a problem
from the numerator i can't let the
numerator equal 0 because
that would not be an imaginary number so
i am now
also excluding in addition to excluding
z equals i
i have to exclude z equals 1. so
from there now that i've noted my domain
discontinuities
because i was it's i sort of flagged it
earlier on i then have to look at
this part here you remember if the
numerator is zero
the whole thing is equal to zero so i'm
going to take this
and so long as i solve for this being
equal to 0
and note my other discontinuities from
before i should get
i should get the right locus so let's
have a look at this
what shape is this well it's not
immediately obvious but i do notice that
there's a positive x squared and there's
a positive y
squared so where my brain is going is i
think i should complete the square that
will help it make more
make it more obvious what kind of shape
this is so if i gather over here
x squared minus x to complete the square
on this term i have to take this
coefficient here which is negative
1 i have to halve it and square it half
and square so when you halve it you get
negative a half and when you square it
you get a quarter
you do the same thing for the y's so
because the coefficients are the same
so you add a quarter here now because
you added a quarter
to the x terms and you added a quarter
to the y
terms well i did anyway you're going to
have to add it to the right hand side as
well so a quarter
plus a quarter i might as well actually
just write a quarter plus a quarter
and we'll simplify on the next line as a
half
in exactly the same way on the left hand
side i can do some more simplification
here
these two sets of brackets these
trinomials they're perfect squares they
don't look like it because they're
fractions but they are perfect squares
it's x minus a half squared remember
this is the thing that we we we halved
it and got to here
and you square it to come up to this if
you were expanding so same deal over
here it's y
minus a half squared so this is just
a circle i know where its center is it's
a half
plus a half i and then i know what its
radius will be it's going to be
the square root of this which is 1 on
root 2. so let's go ahead and draw that
so i'm going to draw this over here
that looks like a decent looking set of
axes
and then i've got a circle now uh
think about this for a second we said
that you're going to have a um
a center of a half
plus a half i right so therefore my
center should be
about there but then because i have a
radius of
one on root two you have to think about
where are there
gonna be any relevant intercepts right
and there is well there are i should say
if you have a think about going from
this point here this point i should
actually label it a half plus a half i
what will be the distance from this
center to
the origin what would be the modulus of
that central point
well you can see i hope that because
this distance is a half
and this horizontal distance is also a
half
using pythagoras you can confirm for
yourself that you're going to get
1 on root 2 as your hypotenuse
so therefore since that's the hypotenuse
and that is actually the radius of the
circle because
this is equal to 1 on root 2 or squared
right the circle is actually going to
its circumference is going to pass
through
this this origin over here because
that's one of the points that's the
the right distance from the center so
therefore i'm going to just roughly draw
this and then i'm going to fix it up
there we go obviously i'd use like an
actual compass or something like that if
i was doing this
accurately but i think
maybe should be a bit bigger there we go
that's not that's not too bad i think
that's our that's close enough for me so
there's my
circle and it has the correct radius and
the correct
center i actually feel like it should be
a little bit bigger but you get the idea
there we go i'm more happy with that it
goes through the origin as i pointed out
but you can see here that i need to
exclude these two points that i noticed
before
right where z equals i well z equals i
is if this is
uh if this is half i then i is up in
this
corner over here so therefore i need to
put a hollow circle
at i and let's um let's go over that so
you can see it's truly hollow
okay and in the same way i need to put
in
a hollow circle at z equals 1 which is
down here in the bottom right hand
corner
and i can see that that should be the
right scale so i'll just
fill that in so this point over here is
one they are not included
but every other point on the
circumference is
r so what's our conclusion um
you had to do quite a lot of thinking to
get through this question firstly you
had to
convert this into an appropriate form we
realize because of
the separation of real and imaginary and
also because we're sketching
that cartesian form would be most useful
to us we had to do a lot of work
once we got it into cartesian form to
separate out the real
and the imaginary parts and then if you
want reals you need
no imaginary bits if you want imaginary
you mean no real bits but you also need
to be quite cautious
because of these um these hidden domain
restrictions
that we noticed first from the
denominator but then even from
the numerator if you want a number to be
imaginary 0
is not allowed so i hope that's helpful
think carefully
draw your diagrams nice and big so you
can do your geometric reasoning on the
diagram
as you've seen here and you'll be able
to tackle questions like this in the
future